ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi stiamo
per fare uno dei prodotti più famosi e
amati nel mondo
stiamo parlando della nutella un pochino
di settimane fa ho ricevuto su whatsapp
questo nome
da una parte vediamo la nutella
dall'altra vediamo tutti gli ingredienti
che la compongono divisi a strati in
realtà non è proprio questo che ho
ricevuto perché è quello che ho ricevuto
io non si può far vedere ma mi sono
subito chiesto se questi sono veramente
gli ingredienti presenti all'interno
della nutella che cosa ci vuole a farla
perché le deriso non era una battuta il
ragionamento non fa una piega e
risultato si può variare comunque
partiamo scusa se di sicuro non si fa
vedere era 12 delle pagine viste e bello
vedere perché dunque farlo allora
facevano vedere il network
partiamo subito col procedimento per
fare la nutella avremo bisogno di olio
di palma che non è presente all'interno
di supermercati quindi abbiamo trovato
un'alternativa che è un olio di semi di
girasole certi dimetti delle palme sopra
e fingersi olio di palma olio di palma
latte in polvere che è introvabile e
quindi alla fine abbiamo trovato latte
crescita dai 2 ai 3 anni della mellin ho
dei dubbi che questa cosa funzioni però
volevamo essere più fedeli alla ricetta
possibile cacao in polvere mandorle
tostate ma comando è riuscito perciò del
grosso quanto una casa
bravo e attento
la cia le crostate e zucchero zucchero
posso dire che personalmente sono
veramente curioso di vedere se questa
roba funziona non so quanto sia in
realtà capito una roba sensazionalistica
della serie guarda quanto zucchero ti
mangi mi sembra un po esagerato e infine
avremo bisogno di lui
un barattolo misuratore della nutella
ragazzi parliamoci chiaro cioè con ogni
probabilità non faremo la nutella perché
stiamo seguendo un meme manco la ricetta
originale mano curioso di vedere quanto
realistico fosse e siccome non sono
stupido oltre al barattolino che noi
riempiremo o anche una piccola porzione
di nutella reale per poterle assaggiare
e vedere quanto si avvicina o quanto sia
lontana dal consiglio del web
partiamo allora teoricamente lo zucchero
prende un terzo ma occhio ragazzi anche
di più se non ci può stare
nocciole tritate le nocciole tritate che
non vedo l'ora di tritare
grande il potere la nutella h c'è un
bello strato città sta cacao leggermente
di meno vero
mi sento veramente in gamba se ma io non
ho fatto altro nella vita è adesso il
momento che preferisco il latte per il
bebè da due a tre anni
io però vorrei quello che non c'entra
niente con l'altro in polvere e sono
tornati indietro nel che ha ricordato
qualcosa provatura dda dati del torneo
nel tempo buono e vabbè che manca pure
che faceva schifo che schifo fa in
questa roba trochei e infine olio quello
che direi di fare io adesso è votarlo
qua dentro e frullare non ho idea di
cosa aspettarmi cioè mi sembra assurdo
capito
troppo liquida ragazzi ho bisogno
dell'aiuto del web come fare la nutella
a una spilla casa qui è la maglietta del
pride che ha fatto ralph lauren appena
c'era la teoria o beccato chef stefano
barbato questo video di lui e quindi ci
siamo contenti di arrivare sempre
qualche anno dopo lite alle ricette la
cuoce a bagnomaria
troviamo infatti che aspettiamo ormai
almeno qualcosa viene fuori non ha una
bella faccia brutta mostruosa il calore
di solvay tante cose umano e non
probabile flop
no non essere così uno chef barbato
aveva usato altre doti che certo ma noi
siamo seguendo quelli del nome di casa
una tredicenne che stai facendo non
vieni
ecco di un il tuo parere infatti sa il
quale secondo me il segreto riesce a
barbato che quando lui è imparato era
silenzioso avrà rubato con gli occhi
siccome chef barbato e orly da ragazzi
fare da vero pesto
io vorrei vedere quando lo zucchero
inizia a sciogliersi allora cosa succede
e poi soprattutto il processo di maiale
è come se li dentro le avessi messo una
piccola dose di intenda sì è vero ora
dedico a me
è qui no ragazzi e poi fa un motore
raccapricciante allora posso provare una
cosa l'ho versiamo all'interno di questo
browser cui e lo lasciamo riposare
forse te lo dico una delle cose più o
non è che sotto sotto il latte ma ti
marino poi riscaldare per il tuo bambino
il motivo
il 30 un sacco dario e mezzo d'oro e
cervello dei mette fondamentali un
fallimento ma dobbiamo assaggiare ti
giuro si farà cagare pantaloni jeans
sbottonati che questa la sensazione che
mi abbiano invertito il processo della
catena alimentare
facciamo riposare questo liquame lì
quella la riprendiamo fra tra un po
capace anche lasciamo riposare ragazze
mi tutti è inutile aspettare questo è
quello che succede quando si ascolta la
voce dei meme la voce dei miei mi dice
solamente una cosa né me né una voce vo
centrica che non cerca la verità
possiamo noi coerenti
cinque ingredienti casa la moglie di
roger rabbit stato io prima non ti è
piaciuto ma che cavalca senti
infinitesimale non tutto il cucchiaio
ragazzi non è malvagio non è
agghiacciante
[Applauso]
ma di che stiamo parlando
mai vista mai vista una cosa così
fallimentare ragazzi questo qui
naturalmente non è un video che vi
invita a riprovare a fare questa ricetta
noi siamo costretti per colpa tua e
delle idee ad assaggiare quello c'è da
dire che non si può sempre ritirare il
capitano con del mare mosso
se poi ti porta con la sua nave lontano
è vero andiamo a dormire sapendo di aver
fallito per essere più forti
domani quando troveremo il mare piatto e
la nave
a parte gli scherzi ci dispiace
veramente aver derubato minuti preziosi
della nostra vita
io sono in imbarazzo sono dispiaciuto
seguito a questo punto la ricetta dice
barbato che mettiamo nel link in
descrizione non è la nutella ma comunque
una cosa che alla fine io come sempre
l'invito iscrivervi a questo canale se
noi abbiamo strappato una risata ma
soprattutto ad attivare la campanella
delle notifiche per non perdere i
prossimi video noi ci vediamo la
prossima domenica sempre ai 12 con una
nuova puntata di cucina buttata ciao
comunque io penso che tu ci debba delle
cure sì scusatemi ragazza velata io
pensavo che sarebbe stata tipo cavolo
tagliate tutto